the document that the assicom that the sic a
3g
the edson morelli coming down from the cmac that
here the iqa merry sticc this is
sociology psychology anthropology of
being afraid of a vehicle and hit kakã
chakana saw the small ship a
positive shock and change saw i came  family
stayed for a minute i saw him complied
with the one with the skull that already wool so-and-so in the
blockages that she perceived from the club
my goal it's ok not to see even with
bernard da da family da kombi no they
da activa was beautiful in the block  t in
africa latin america and pure and came out with
a chassis on pt ac that is walking tape
i have to tell you about the
practicability and it still fell during the
day yesterday it gives a little bit of the rhythm of the
bottled nobody
the cane in 2009 even recognizes thinking
that he was going to lose and always went to the house in
the tequila square, coined a no and that
only with which it is jump from timon to kill
also highlighting a little the pain not being
a black man who saw the woman understand how
classic it is and me here to serve as  not you  gives
vitor leo gil and davi with which the public
with demi portimonense left